مستوى مذهل من الاحتيال وعندما تقوم
بإلقاء نظرة عليه ،
إذا كان هناك أي شيء كان ثابتًا
بشأنه ، فهو
عملية احتيال تلاعب بالنظام
كونه مخادعًا ، استمع إلى أن تأجيلات مسودته
كانت احتيالًا كانت درجاته في السلس
عملية
احتيال.
إن استقطاعاته في استماراته الضريبية هي عملية
احتيال ،
هل يعتقد أي شخص أنه أنفق سبعين
ألف دولار على تصفيف الشعر
فقط إذا تم اتهامه بشعره ، فكل
شيء عن هذا الرجل
يفوز بالمؤسسة الخيرية الرابحة في الجامعة
، وسأخبرك ما الذي يدفعني
للجنون
عندما  فكر في كل الأشخاص الذين
يتخلصون
ويعملون بجد كل الأشخاص الشرفاء الذين
يدفعون ضرائبهم
والذين يجدون صعوبة في تدبير
نفقاتهم ، تعلمون من يدفع ضرائب أكثر من
دونالد يتفوق
على المهاجرين غير الشرعيين في ملاعب الجولف
التي أطلقها عندما اكتشف المراسلون
كان لديه مهاجرون غير
شرعيين يدفعون ضرائب أكثر مما دفعه دونالد ترامب
أبراهام لينكولن
في عام 1864 ضرائب أكثر
مما دفعه دونالد ترامب قبل 151 عامًا
وهو دفع أكثر  في صمت الأموال إلى دانيلز العاصفة
مما يدفعه في الضرائب ، إنه أمر مثير للاشمئزاز
أنه منافق ، إنه غير
مقبول وأنا أعلم أنه لن
يغير رأي قاعدته ،
لكني آمل أن
تأخذ قطعة صغيرة جدًا من الناخبين المترددين  انظر إلى
هذا وأدرك أنه لا يمكن أن يكون لدينا رجل في
الرئاسة يستخدم الرئاسة ومنبر الفتوة
للترويج وبيع
العضويات في ناديه وفي ملاعب الجولف
الخاصة به ودفع الأعمال الحكومية التي تعرفها
إلى ممتلكاته من أجل الادخار.
علامته التجارية لا يمكننا تحمل
ذلك كدولة ، فهو ليس سوى عملية احتيال